I know you travel all around the world
you're performing you're a global star
now you just performed in Australia is
that right yeah how is there a few weeks
ago I toured in Australia I did a
Melbourne Sydney Brisbane it was a lot
of fun it was it nice here you like the
people I I do uh they have some
interesting slang there one thing that I
really liked was uh they say house when
they wanted to say something's bad that
they uh don't go there mate house really
that's their term for something's not
good yeah that means outhouse yeah
and then I heard some woman say yeah and
that one's easy
yeah we'd figured maybe just like a
house you only take I don't know
actually me yeah so that's what I wanted
to make it clear you did the right thing
but uh so I I heard people say like that
and then I heard a woman say like oh my
god he's gorgeous she's built like a
house and I was like that's strange so
he's like so massive you could put a
toilet inside him I'd use it as a
restroom outdoors yeah no confusion
confusion now you are a quite successful
fellow life seems to be going well how
was your social life I want to know
about that what's going on there good
I'm just a single guy I'm not married
I'm not don't have kids or anything like
that all my friends are getting married
and stuff which is uh kind of strange
you're not sure you're down with that
idea I don't know I mean I feel like I
see people my age getting married to
people and like it's not people they
know that well sometimes like getting
married to people they've known for like
a year and a half it's like a year and a
half is that enough time to get to know
someone to know you want spend the rest
of your life with them a year and a half
I've had sweaters for a year and half of
it like was I doing this sweater
so so you're really you think people
should know each other longer than that
is that it you think yeah I mean I don't
know it's it's just a scary proposition
like you're you're you're trying to say
this is the person you're gonna spend
the rest of your life with it's a big
deal you know III don't know I mean one
thing I love about marriages oh I I do
love the proposal I think that's really
fascinating because this is this is a
moment you know you're gonna change the
life of yourself and this person you
love forever you know and you can make
it the most beautiful amazing special
romantic moment you can do that you plan
it out you make it perfect you don't get
to do that with most big moments and
you're like what the proposal again
Nocona and you're married yes what did
you do to make it the most beautiful
amazing special perfect moment as my
manager caller what do you know I hurt
me what city were in I was actually in
Connecticut at the time my wife and I
went out at my current wife my wife and
I went to the country my girlfriend then
and I had the ring ready and I you know
asked her and yeah so you're like in
Connecticut like we're like in like a
you're getting real specific here I was
out in a nice sort of bed and breakfast
area and we had gone there for the
weekend and we were hanging out and I
sort of acted like nothing was going on
and then she was born she's like you
know what do you want to what should we
do now should we go to the movies and I
said we could do that or we could get
married and she oh the rain to go you
know it sounds like you were like in
some like field in Connecticut she was
part of like Conan's gonna murder me I'm
so scared
I see it was getting really dark and I
said you will marry me
or you will find you I have to see you
that was that was the plan be the murder
part that sounds very sweet thought it
was sweet it was nice I think if you're
gonna propose I think you should do
something nice and sweet and special
because what you're asking of this
person is an insane thing it doesn't
seem insane because you know we're all
familiar with marriages and institution
but like imagine if marriage didn't
exist and your guy and you're asking a
woman to get married like imagine what
that conversation would be you know
you'd be like hey so you know how we've
been spend a lot of time together doing
a lot of stuff together hanging out and
everything oh yeah yeah I know I want to
keep doing that till you're dead
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you want to keep hanging out with you
till one of us dies put this ring on
your finger so people know we have an
arrangement who's that guy that's
walking up here sir priest I want you to
swear to God you won't back out of this
dude this is everything I used in the
field yeah